you want to experience some of that
classic [ __ ] that there's like nobody
on record even like rating or evaluating
it right
[Music]
hello i'm adam22 and today i'm answering
the internet if you could have one
person narrate or do play-by-play of you
having sex who would it be probably uh
rick ross and i would just hope that he
would stick a lot of
in there you know
if you could put any franchise
restaurant in your house what would it
be i'm probably going to go with arby's
because i'm a big roast beef guy right
babe
[Laughter]
what are your top three gas station
snacks of all time wow funny you
mentioned that because uh i used to be a
heavy 7-eleven
pursuer and i would always go in there
and i would get the egg salad sandwich
on white bread i would get the cheez-its
and i would get the carrot cake and i
felt like this was a well-balanced meal
yeah i was living i was living large if
you had to choose one cartoon animal to
have sex with who would it be i'm trying
to think of like who's the most female
presenting maybe bambi that's a deer bro
just having sex with a deer dude yeah
but it's still like feminine energy and
i feel like you know
like but like minnie mouse is just like
mickey mouse with a skirt on
is there any cartoon animal that i
wouldn't have sex with
how many rats would it take to overwhelm
and kill you in a fight well this is
actually a real possibility because
there's a whole lot of rats running
around the hip-hop game
these days but you know i feel like if i
had 300 rats coming towards me that i
might just give up and lay down and die
but there's nowhere to run like how many
are you gonna be able to stomp on ten
rats i could like maybe stomp on and
would you even wanna live after that
right i'd be so traumatized yeah what
the [ __ ] if you had to watch your
biggest enemy [ __ ] the girl of your
dreams in order for you to marry her
would you do it
well it turns out i've already gaslit
the girl in my dreams into marrying me
without having to watch anybody else
[ __ ] her so uh
i don't know if the juice is worth the
squeeze on that one man that sounds kind
of rough like
can i take a couple of xanax first so i
don't remember it
if someone texted you a picture of your
dick with no contacts would you know
that it's your dick yes 100 my dick is
very familiar to me i spent a lot of
time looking at it both from my own
perspective and on camera so i i watch
each episode before it comes out so i
know what my [ __ ] looks like
i actually feel like i kind of [ __ ] my
back up because i go like this too much
because like when you're filming
when you're filming this looks a lot
better than this
and so i've noticed myself actually
[ __ ] my backup which is honestly kind
of sad
would you rather a throw up any time
that anyone says mcdonald's or b wear a
fedora for the rest of your life and if
anybody asks you about it you have to
say i like the way it looks
i mean i hate puking but i can't rock no
fedora man i'm i'm going with a i'm not
rocking a fedora i just refuse
would you rather always come prematurely
or never come at all well this is my
theory is that in the porn world like
most guys gravitate towards one or the
other where they're like it's hard for
them to [ __ ] for a long time because
they're gonna come too fast or it's hard
for them to finish because it's hard to
come i personally am the person who's
like closer to like nutting at any given
moment like i'm genuinely into it but if
i had to choose one always come
prematurely so like even if i'm on round
four i still come prematurely
or never come at all jesus christ these
are terrible but you prefer
uh i would prefer you came from a
shirley i guess i don't want you to not
not that sad that's so nice of you don't
get me pregnant but never come at all
means that i just get to be out there
with just a [ __ ] just a an arm on me
just going
67 minutes i'm gonna hate you
but it's not about you
would you rather your girlfriend be able
to read your thoughts during sex or all
the time except during sex
to be honest i'm not thinking about
anything when we're having sex that i'd
be worried about you knowing about like
the worst thing that would enter my mind
is like a threesome that we did like
three years ago that for some reason i'm
kind of embarrassed that is like it's
popping into my head
well then you should know if you smell
bad i'm just gonna tell you so i mean
i think yeah she can read my thoughts
during sex that's fine but outside of
sex that could be a lot more dangerous
if you had to move it to a different
place on the body where would you put
the vagina
i've always been trying to figure out
what a an armpit was all about but i
never really actually wanted to go for
it and i feel like all the sweat from
the armpit is probably not actually a
good lubricant
but if you could have some [ __ ] juice
in there like
maybe
it's like your balls like you know it
sucks having balls right here that if i
kick you in your balls it's gonna hurt
really bad but where else would you put
them right they're pretty like kept away
from everything you know yeah
damn do you think there are more porn
stars or murderers in the world if our
definition of porn star includes
just anybody who's ever had an only fans
or maybe like sold a photo
then for sure porn star but if we're
talking like actual like real porn stars
who have shot for a real company i think
you have to think like the percentage of
people who have killed someone in
america is probably so low compared to a
lot of other
countries so i think for sure and
there's probably almost nobody doing
porn in a lot of those countries too so
porn is one thing that almost nobody
gets to keep a secret and a murder
ideally you get to keep a secret so yeah
see this is so embarrassing because i'm
so bad with mainstream celebrities
mary [ __ ] kill brad pitt
matthew mcconaughey channing tatum so
brad pitt fight club whatever heartthrob
from when i was in high school
he's cool matthew mcconaughey
the guy who gave the speech about guns
the other day that's how you know
he
is
i don't know i don't watch movies i
watch movies and i don't learn the names
she she has heard me have this
conversation about like infinite
celebrities because i really
yeah channing tatum no
clue that a sports dude or something no
he's an athlete yeah 21 jump street
movie i'm going to say no
i'm just going to say brad pitt for all
of them because i don't know who these
other dudes are
[Laughter]
if you could have anyone in history on
plug talk who would you pick oh for sure
we're including the dead right
audrey hepburn audrey hepburn
monroe so it's funny that you went there
too yeah you want to experience some of
that classic [ __ ] that there's like
nobody on record even like rating or
evaluating it right well you know what
nancy reagan after that yeah was she hot
apparently nancy reagan is what they
call the throat goat of hollywood back
in the day she really sucked everybody's
dick and was like the queen i want that
monica lewinsky top too and i want to
see bill before he dies so i can i could
be like hey bro me and you
all right big thanks for watching ati
anybody else who you want to see any
up-and-coming comics anybody who you
think deserves to be a superstar comment
below we'll go get em make sure you
subscribe to the channel right now